one of only three Republicans to vote
for it remarkably was Matt gates of
Florida who was one of the president's
closest allies maybe he's single closest
ally in the house represents he joins us
now
kongstrup thanks so much for coming on
so I think it's fair to say you're
certainly one of the people in the House
closest to the president he's completely
opposed to this you as his close ally
voted for it tell us why you did that I
spoke to the president today after one
of America's brave Patriots was laid
down at Arlington one of my constituents
who passed away just days before
Christmas in Afghanistan and the
president told me he's more anti-war
than I am and I love the president for
that Tucker the thing is I think you've
got a few of the advisors of the
president who are trying to slow walk
the administration into war when the
president relies on his instincts and we
have the Trump doctrine we kill the
terrorists and we come home and I think
this War Powers Resolution was worthy of
support because it did not criticize the
president it did not say he was wrong
and killing Soleimani
but he did it did say that if any
president wants to drag our nation into
another forever Middle East war that
they require the approval of the United
States Congress that's something I
deeply believe and I think it's
something the president deeply believes
so why wouldn't I mean first of all I
think that the Constitution requires
that I think is pretty obvious but it
does but why why wouldn't Congress if
they're so in favor of a military action
put themselves on the record endorsing
it it seems like one of the reasons
people oppose this is because they're
afraid they're cowards in the Congress
it's it's unfortunate that I think we
have members of Congress that depart
from what the framers and founders
believed would happen they believe that
we would closely guard our article one
powers and that we would ensure that no
president would be able to take those
away in in in any sort of affront to
what was intended for us to be our
responsibility it's my belief that
declaring war is a non-delegable duty of
the United States Congress and it's
ludicrous for any of my colleagues to
suggest that we have to not do our job
so that people in uniform can do theirs
we can actually do both Tucker yeah it's
just so just be totally clear you're one
of three Republicans who voted
in effect against the president's stated
position but she just talked to the
president and he said that he's on your
side well the president probably would
have preferred that I vote with the
other Republicans he certainly said that
but I think on these broader questions
of war and peace Donald Trump
understands that the pro war candidate
loses presidential elections Hillary
Clinton was more Pro war and lost and if
you look previously it's typically the
anti-war candidates that won I think
since 9/11 John Kerry was the only
anti-war candidate that lost an election
and so I think that the president
understands that and he's too smart to
let Nancy Pelosi try to cast him as the
pro-war candidate and that's why I don't
think we're going to war with Iran I
think I think that's exists more
analysis congressman thanks so much for
explaining that I appreciate it thank
you